[Music]
ninety-five percent of the people who
get arrested or go to jail they're
coming out tonight gonna die in prison
than that so what we're gonna do about
there are no people in my spirit there's
very free people rather that are solely
incorrigibles that they woke up
genetically you know genetically a sign
to do harm to society it's very very
Psychopaths most people are responding
to environmental triggers so if we can
take those triggers out and give them
other triggers they would be as whole
and as normal as we are mistake feel
normal people when you believe this when
you believe you're in a jungle you say I
have to become more animal but the truth
is when if you're in a jungle you got to
become more human more strategic because
you came out animal to lion you got out
thinking see strong ruler weak but the
wise rule them all so you have to figure
out how to create thoughts that govern
this jungle but if no one told you that
you just go to your Lord nature and say
survival of the fittest and you know
whenever I'm just gonna push high and
whenever it ends and ends and that's the
fatalistic view of life and so you got a
you got a reprogram that but here's the
good news it is always appropriate to
give someone a second chance when they
ask for it because the sincerity of the
acts will give you more room for their
personal growth you don't matter that
they that they are trying it again and
again I tell young people all the time
if you keep trying that you getting
closer to the point where you actually
do what you say you're gonna do that's
to go working in the penal system for
five years what I realize is it's a
breeding ground it's it's a housing is
not an eruptive of behavior when it
comes down to pro-social behavior it can
get you pathologically on the path to go
as far as you can take it here the
negativeness
it does not give you real sound options
because it is like being in a in a and
an ultraviolet or a tanning booth with
no relief in sight
it burns you it Sears into your skin
your DNA you become that see so so if
you're not careful the prison system
becomes a breeding ground for behaviors
that we say are not social well meaning
people with a bad system that they're
trying to manage those who leave it and
then well-intended people who trying to
get out but they saying to get out I
have to say this but to stay alive while
I mean I have to be this you always have
multiple multiple personalities you
become this different person so in the
chow hall you saying I'll shank you but
in front of your case manager you saying
I'm repentant and so and so you don't
know what you want you faking with you
know you could be faking with the appeal
or you could be faking with but either
one of them you're not being real so my
role when I was worked in prison was to
take all those masks off
like we would do this box man and it was
powerful but when we worked in prison I
was I would say what did you love what
did you hate whether you fear and what
do you need and I will put you don't
have them put their name in the box so
that's the real you so I gotta keep you
in this box so you'd know who you are
cause if you're talking about this box
man you you you will react differently
when you're not you because they were
safe I said man what's your name my name
oh jeez not nothing you know push it in
my name I said okay tell me who you are
not your character not the person you
play and child not the one you try to
convince to let you out but let me get
you
and then when they can do that in a
place that's that that's that that
intense and they can be vulnerable in
that intense place and make it it gives
them power over their environment so
they can say well maybe I can shape this
environment to be a breeding a a seeding
ground not just a breeding ground I can
play some good season then you can grow
to hawk
[Music]